im Norden Parkplatz
Sarah Abdel Karim hatems Familie liebte
hier
ihre vier Schwestern ihr junger Bruder
ihre Eltern
vor 15 Jahren wurden sie genau hier von
amerikanischen Raketen getötet
sah das Geschichte ist eine von
tausenden aber sie ist eine der wenigen
die sich traut mit uns zu sprechen
meine Kinder fragen mich nach
Erinnerungen aber ich kann mich nicht
erinnern als ob die Heftigkeit des
Schocks alles ausradiert hat eine Woche
vor ihrem Tod besuchte ich meine Eltern
sie waren so zärtlich so liebevoll zu
mir ich will darüber sprechen weil wir
im Irak bis heute mit Schmerzen leben
ich bin weil ich wissen will was die
US-Invasion 2003 für das Leben im Irak
bedeutet
sarah ist Angestellte im Ölministerium
ihr Mann ist Taxifahrer für Sie bedeutet
das Leben vor allem Angst und Verlust es
bedeutet ein Krieg nach dem anderen ein
Leben in extremen und ein nie
verarbeiteter Schock
es wird gesagt dass es unter Saddam
Hussein Massengräber gab aber wie viele
Massengräber sind seit 2003 ausgehoben
worden wie viele Kinder zu weisen
geworden wie viele Häuser verbrannten es
gibt keine Familie ohne einen getöteten
oder Hingerichteten
nur einige verwackelte Aufnahmen vom
Angriff der Amerikaner blieben ihr das
Elternhaus war nur noch Schutt und Staub
darin verkohlte Leichen
das US-Militär entschuldigte sich bei
ihr der Tod ihrer Familie sei ein wie
Sie sagten militärischer Fehler gewesen
ein Fehler von tausenden sagt sie
seit 2003 haben nach Schätzungen mehr
als eine halbe Million Iraker ihr Leben
verloren durch Krieg Bürgerkrieg und
Kriminalität jeden Tag hat Sarah hat ihm
Angst um ihre Söhne sie sagt sie kenne
niemanden der sich nicht die Zeit vor
der US-Invasion zurückwünsche unter
Diktator Saddam Hussein
wenn ich mit meinen Kollegen spreche
merke ich wie jeder diesen Schmerz hat
seitdem Saddam Hussein Weg ist lebt
niemand ruhig und friedlich
Freiheit Freiheit gibt es ja nicht
Freiheit kenne nur einige wenige haben
sie gesehen wie viele Journalisten
getötet wurden sie erhoben ihre Stimme
und wurden am Ende dafür getötet
nichts hält sie im Irak sagt sie es
könne eines der reichsten Länder der
Welt sein aber das Land kollabiere statt
sich weiterzuentwickeln ist Sarah Hatem
überzeugt denn für die an der Macht sei
das Volk nur ein lästiges Übel
der Irak heute instabile und zerbrochen
die Wunden der vergangenen Jahre lassen
sich kaum heilen
[Musik]
solche Szenen der Premierminister neben
gestohlenen Dollar bündeln die der Staat
wiedergefunden hat stehen für eines der
korruptesten Länder der Welt
geschätzt über 300 Milliarden Dollar
verschwanden seit 2003
Leben im Irak viele Menschen haben es
satt täglich Schmiergelder zu zahlen
tägliche Stromausfälle zu erleben keine
Chancen zu haben und die Interessen des
Nachbars Iran vor die eigenen zu stellen
immer neue Tote im Namen der Demokratie
haben die USA das Land ethnisch und
religiös gespalten mehr denn je regierte
Iran in das Land hinein wo er seine
terrorspur hinterlässt herrscht Angst
Sigrid nördlich von Bad
eine riesige schiitische Fahne weht am
Eingang jener Stadt in der der
sunnitische Clan zadam Husseins
beheimatet war
die zerstörten Paläste des einstigen
Diktators sind schwer Zone sie werden
bewacht von Pro iranischen schiitischen
Milizen die gegen die sunnitischen
Einwohner Misstrauen hegen
selbst ein entfernter Verwandter verdamm
Husseins
das Leben der Menschen hier ist immer
bedroht ich bin einer der bedrohten
meine Freunde auch wenn sie keine
Drohungen bekommen dann bekommen sie
Probleme bei der Arbeit oder werden
ihrer Rechte beraubt je nachdem wie weit
wir die rote Linie der Milizen
überschreiten
ist Aktivist er kämpft für einen
demokratischen Irak ohne Korruption für
eine irakische Nation einen Staat für
alle Iraker frei von der Kontrolle Irans
seine Milizen und Parteien deren
Straftaten im Irak bis heute ungeahndet
geblieben sind
es gibt so viel Angst sie beherrscht die
Menschen hier die gesamte Gesellschaft
viele mächtige da oben benutzen diese
Angst halten sie aufrecht durch die
bewaffneten Milizen und deren Verbündete
in den Sicherheitsorganen des Landes
kümmert sich um die vielen einfachen
Menschen die Angst haben zu sprechen
Flüchtlingsfrauen aus sunnitischen
Gebieten für die er Spenden sammelt ihre
Väter Söhne Brüder sind seit Jahren
verschwunden
zehntausende wurden verschleppt sehr
wahrscheinlich von Pro iranischen
schiitischen Milizen
bringt mir meine Söhne zurück nur das
ich würde alles tun mich von Staub und
Wasser ernähren nur um sie zurück zu
bekommen
was diesen Menschen wieder fuhr ist die
Tat bewaffneter Milizen getrieben von
konfessionalem Hass das sind illegale
Gruppen mit illegalen Waffen wenn unsere
Regierung zu dieser Katastrophe schweigt
dann beteiligt sie sich an dieser
Straftat
der Staat erklärte die verschleppten
kürzlich für tot
weder ermittelt er wie das passierte
noch unterstützt er die
Flüchtlingsfamilie wo der Nachbar Iran
seine Hand im Spiel hat Schweigen Iraks
verantwortliche